das ist echt eine kollision der
besonderen art gleich drei schwarze
löcher drohen ist ihre gegenseitig
gravitation zusammenzustoßen
bei klicks um science-fiction gibt's
alle neuigkeiten aus der welt der
wissenschaft abonniert den kanal
aktiviert die glocke um nichts zu
verpassen
die heutige folge moderiere ich tim von
astrotv in der abwesenheit von christoph
viel spaß
schwarze löcher sind die mysteriösen
bösewichte des universums obwohl man
immer noch nicht genau weiß wie sie
funktionieren hat man in den letzten
jahren große fortschritte bei ihrer
erforschung erzielt man weiß dass
schwarze löcher ihre unfassbare wirkung
durch gravitation entfalten
sie sind so schwer und verdichtet dass
sie nicht nur planeten und sterne
einsaugen können sondern sogar das licht
daher auch der name schwarzes loch bis
2016 gab es sogar noch wissenschaftler
die bestritten haben dass schwarze
löcher überhaupt existieren
doch dann kam der ultimative beweis
gravitationswellen diese entstehen wenn
schwarze löcher kollidieren
diese kosmischen craze sind so massiv
dass raum und zeit zu vibrieren beginnen
mit sehr teuren gerätschaften kann man
dieses vibrieren messen seit der
entdeckung von kollidierenden schwarzen
löchern hat man gemerkt dass das gar
nicht so selten vorkommt doch das gleich
drei dieser kosmischen ungetüme
ineinander krachen dass es dann doch
relativ selten
genau das hat ein team von forschern und
forscherinnen jetzt aber in einer
milliarde lichtjahren entfernung mit
hilfe des röntgenteleskop chandra
entdeckt die schwarzen löcher sind nicht
alleine unterwegs sondern bilden jeweils
den kern einer ganzen galaxie die drei
galaxien zusammen tragen den nicht ganz
so eingängigen namen sds sj 08 49 plus 1
14 galaxien sind riesige ansammlung von
milliarden sternen und in ihrer mitte
befindet sich immer ein supermassives
schwarzes loch das die galaxie in ihrer
form es kann vorkommen dass galaxien so
nahe beieinander sind dass sie sich
gegenseitig anziehen und dann irgendwann
kollidieren
dabei kommt es natürlich auch zur
kollision der supermassiven schwarzen
löcher wenn zwei schwarze löcher sich
treffen verschmelzen die zu einem noch
schwerer und schwarzen loch dessen
einzugsbereich noch größer
dass die drei nun entdeckten galaxien
sind so nah beieinander dass die
schwarzen löchern nur noch ca 10.000
lichtjahre trennen kosmisch gesehen ist
das also ein katzensprung aber was
geschieht wenn drei schwarze löcher
kollidieren
es könnte geschehen dass sie sich in
einem kosmischen todes tanz umeinander
bewegen und durch den drehimpuls dann
eines der schwarzen löcher weg
geschleudert wird
so könnte ein marodierende schwarzes
loch entstehen dass dann wahllos durch
die galaxie rast sterne und planeten
verschlingt und vielleicht sogar
irgendwann seine eigene galaxie verlässt
unsere milchstraße betritt und die erde
aufsaugt nicht gerade wahrscheinlich
aber auch nicht unmöglich übrigens steht
auch uns eine galaxie kollision bevor
unsere nachbargalaxie andromeda und
unsere milchstraße rasen mit einem
affenzahn aufeinander zu und werden in
einigen milliarden jahren
zusammentreffen
dabei werden natürlich auch die beiden
schwarzen löcher der galaxien
verschmelzen mal schauen ob dann noch
menschen da sein werden um das spektakel
mitzuerleben
hoffen wir mal dass wir von
marodierenden schwarzen löchern
verschont bleiben falls sie aber
erfahren wollen was passiert wenn ein
mensch ins schwarze loch fliegt dann
schaut euch mal dieses video auf meinem
channel astro comics tv an
und ich würde mich natürlich mega freuen
wenn ihr meinen channel abonnieren wird
und mein ziel ist es dieses jahr noch
15.000 abos zu erreichen vielleicht
kriegen wir das ja gemeinsam hin
ansonsten macht's gut leute bleibt immer
neugierig bis zum nächsten video